[Music]
so thank you very much for inviting me
access Alliance is a where community
health center we're focused on working
with most vulnerable populations in
Toronto our historical focus has been
immigrant and refugee health but this
has evolved over the years in large part
due to our engagement in community-based
research and so our understanding as an
organization is that the impact of
systemic barriers which we do address is
multi-generational and impact so we do
have to look at generations in
communities so moving away from that
immigrant and newcomer definition and
also our understanding of the impact of
the racialization of poverty so as a
Community Health Center we made a
decision many many years ago to develop
a community-based research program so
you know in consultation with funders
and you know with the support of our
boards of directors and you know with a
little bit of magic have developed this
capacity this is our vision as you can
see we are systems change focused again
as I said the systemic barriers
individual services and community level
services is very important but we have
to look at changing that system so as a
Community Health Center we are committed
to evidence informed decision-making and
practice so this suggests that were
guided by the best research and
information available and again as an
organization many years ago when we
started thinking about this in a you
know drill-down way that's when we
started encountering that's when we
started developing our approach to
community-based research and our
commitment to
co-creation of knowledge with
communities because from our perspective
from the perspective of our vision and
mission evidence is meaningless if it is
not linked to systemic change so a
commitment to systemic change so that's
our organization we have a research
department embedded in our in our
community health center I'm not the
researcher I'm the executive director so
I'm part of development of the strategic
direction but we do have a senior
researcher on staff who you know was an
academic and came over to the other side
so so I'm gonna talk about some of our
experiences and and things that we've
learned so most of them are self-evident
I like some of think Diane we asked
United Way got feedback from
participants what were they what would
they like to think about Diane talked
about you know we state the obvious and
I thought yeah that's so self evident we
do state the obvious and so what
research has no valuable if it's not
actionable from our perspective while we
have excellent experience working with
amazing academic partners many many many
researchers have very little interest
with the uptake of their research and so
this is this is often linked to how then
research is carried out you know the
kind of institutional structure and
framework drives how the research is
carried out evidence and our experience
is that evidence is valued so on equally
and hierarchically you know randomized
control trial studies and systematic
reviews are on top and qualitative and
community or great literature on the
bottom and we do need to undo this
hierarchical view each type of research
method and evidence has its own unique
value only captures a piece of the story
and it's only in combination that that
they can give us a more complete picture
of our very complex and messy
a reality so I have to I told you gander
I would name him because he helps me do
all my thinking but I sent him a
question by text about something and he
sent me back this answer well it's not
wasn't an answer it's just a thought so
and it's completely on point so I want
to read it this is your Gander shock
yaar our senior research scientist I'm
doing hierarchy is a two-way process
researchers who do large-scale studies
need to come to terms with the fact that
it is logistical II impossible for them
to reach and include marginalised
vulnerable groups in their studies which
is one of my points here there is a
persistent problem of
under-representation and under count of
marginalized groups in large scale or
randomized control studies including in
census and studies wanting to measure
inequities so they need to reach out and
consider community GRA evidence more
seriously not just in name say community
level investigations including needs
assessments and program evaluation need
to pay closer attention to method
methodological rigor so we have our
piece to work our piece of work to do on
the community side as well you know at
least he says at least write down their
methodology in their report who they
talk to why them what they asked etc so
you know the absence of the most
vulnerable people from study cohorts is
very very problematic and we
consistently flag this so you're right I
mean we've we get called so often from
partners wanting to do studies and our
first question is are you talking to
anybody who doesn't speak English are
you going to be giving snacks at your
focus groups will you be giving TTC
tokens like how do you expect you know
and that's that's very basic and you
know aren't even really the most
impactful access strategies however I do
want to say because it's important for
me at this stage in my career to
acknowledge that there's been massive
change and there is lots of hopeful
things going on in health in terms of
yes the social determinants of health
actually do have something to do with
health so I love this infographic by the
Canadian Medical Association where they
clearly clearly are you know
acknowledging what certainly all of us
working in community
always always known that if you're not
talking about social terms of health
then don't bother so so but so this is
very positive and and you know as I said
we have had a very positive experience
for the most part with researchers this
is some of our from academic researchers
this is some of our learning so our
approach is community-based
participatory action research we work in
communities that have experience that we
have experience with so we don't go into
communities where we're not already
working in a service delivery capacity
or in a community engagement capacity we
recruit train and pay peer researchers
to participate in all our projects this
includes development of questions data
collection coding and identifying
emerging themes co-writing and
development of dissemination vehicles
and participation and knowledge
translation it's extraordinarily messy I
think somebody already said messy takes
a long long long time it's very very
expensive although we managed to do it
on a shoestring because we're totally
under funded and unfunded to do this
kind of work especially the
participatory action base a piece of it
perfect evidence is not a and perfect
evidence is not a reality for us we
identify themes and we start moving
forward with the transformative aspect
of using this knowledge because we are
living in these communities and and we
see the compelling need for change and
and we are working with communities and
it's transformative for them too so they
also want to move you can't control you
can't control that nor would we expect
to it's interesting because this process
you talked about data we have had
challenges around ownership of data
understanding around ownership of data
in particular we've had experiences
where our academic partners have not
wanted our peer researchers who are in
the field doing the research to even
talk about their experiences as peer
researchers let alone findings because
they viewed that as evidence that they
in fact owned and would be controlling
the dissemination of these findings and
it wasn't you know
it's it's not a it's happened more than
once so it's it is a issue and we have
had conversations with with many
partners about this and this is
impossible I mean it's completely
disempowering to to not I mean it's it's
transformative for peer researchers to
do this work in their communities to be
part of thinking about issues and ways
forward and not then support them to be
part of that way forward and and talking
about this especially as that is our
expectation that that's a critical piece
of the research so this is just a little
you know our we use the that one
[Laughter]
you know we strive to ground our model
and ant oppression principles it's
transformative from the beginning is I
mean it was hugely transformative for us
as an organization let alone you know
anything else
so we strive to ground our model and ant
repression principles and practices and
and it is very very messy even our
research coordinators get confused
sometimes as to what their role is and
we've had to love long conversations in
the community you know are they
community workers are the advocates for
community issues are they responsible
for data quality and research rigor it's
it is a complex but at the center you
know are the communities and the
individuals that we work with so at so
I'm going to talk a little bit about the
the participatory system change piece of
the equation now does research evidence
really matter yes but not so much I mean
when you start trying to do systems
change work it's another world
altogether and your there are so many
other factors and we truly do believe
that research only matters if it is
actionable actionable but it is easier
said than done so you know we complain
about community street the research
piece not being well funded well nobody
funds the participatory action so we're
very skilled at burying and disguising
participatory based
advocacy systems change work into you
know a weekly drop in free lunch for
community members or a you know
community meetings with stakeholders so
that's a causative challenge the
environment in the public policy space
is not really receptive to receiving
input I mean better now than it was just
a few months and weeks ago at all levels
of government but still it's not it's
it's not and and there's a huge time
timing disconnect you know I've talked
with people I know who work in policy
roles in government who say by the time
we put something out there as a policy
issue we want to discuss and get input
we were actually down that road we've
actually started making decisions and
mapping pathways so it's like how and
where do you insert yourself it's a huge
disconnect and that's why it's critical
to partner with with advocacy agencies
that are ramped up all the time they
might not be research agency but they're
advocacy agencies so I mean in terms of
partners this is a this is a gig and
relied this was a model developed in
Thailand that's used for health change
policy around the world and it is highly
relevant that's why I'm sharing it with
you today you have to generate relevant
research knowledge in conjunction with
the social movement or social learning
which includes public knowledge and
attitudes and you have to ensure that
the you have to ensure engagement of
political decision-makers including law
lawmakers and the legal system so so
it's you know moving forward on three
fronts and they have to be integrated
and interconnected so you already have
to be thinking about this as you're just
even starting research so I just want to
talk about a couple of case examples
really briefly so a key focus for us has
been the impact on health of vulnerable
people of precarious employment we
started this work well over ten years
ago and we're not the only ones I mean
there's some other reports here it's
you know I would say precarious
employment seems to be a defining
characteristic of the changing world of
work and the reality of this generation
interestingly when we started doing
committee development work in a
high-need neighborhood years before
starting to work on our working rough
living poor project which was a
multi-year undertaking that actually
there were many sort of different
products we thought we were going into
talk about poverty we started doing
focus groups and talking about poverty
and the impact of poverty and it was
community members and youth in
particular who said it's not poverty we
don't want to talk about poverty we want
to talk about employment and the way
that our parents are working that is
impacting our lives and running around
from all of these different jobs and
they're never home but we never have
money and and it's so unstable and it's
horrible and they talked about started
talking about the impact of that in
their communities in their lives and I
mean it was you know that put us on a
path in terms of working with the
community one of the outcomes of this
research so I mean we we did the working
poor working rough living poorer than we
did where the good jobs which is a case
studies ten case studies coming out of
that report and then we were part of a
The Cure with the are like wonder women
and goddesses and robots which was again
a more focused case study looking at the
impact on immigrant women of precarious
employment so we launched you know with
so much of this evidence and other
evidence we launched our call to good
our call to action on good jobs and
we've tried to identify what are steps
towards good jobs and have identified
this broadly we've established community
works group that undertakes actions
based on our knowledge of issues and
we've done a lot of educational work
with health promoters in the health care
system to work with them around how do
they use this evidence in more direct
way and we feel these strategies are
very actionable you know we've got five
you know take them home think about it
what can you do in your organization
there's a lot of initiatives here the
whole decent work initiative to and I
mean we ourselves are complicit in the
whole issue of bad jobs we need to we
need to start at home
and it's interesting you know ax access
alliance our board of directors you know
we committed to $14 minimum pay for all
of our roles last year when we were
working on the minimum wage campaign so
and I get calls from colleagues saying
what are you doing my staff are flipping
me this poster you're they're giving me
a hard time I'm like okay different do
something about it what can I so I mean
we've done Vidya Photovoice a Photovoice
project video op-ed pieces knowledge
translation is is a key piece just
talking about great literature we did a
community health assessment report for
one of our sites where we we take a look
at what data do we have but also what
data exists out there through other
reports we pulled it together and this
was working with a community group that
you know led the review of data and the
prioritization you know we use matrixes
you know what's what does community
think is most serious and most impactful
and then we try then we take that
directly into our program planning and
we link all of these items with
initiatives that either we're trying to
lead or leading with community groups or
we bring this to community tables so
just to wrap hop
you know we this is the action piece we
do have to move forward as I said there
is positive change we have so many
stakeholders in health that are really
stepping up you know Canadian doctors
for refugee health for example and
really doing amazing work which helps
our systems change so some of our
learnings is we have to use evidence as
a strategic catalyst it is all about
strategy if you don't have strategy
there's no point
the partnership piece and a movement a
movement is critical and there are so
many important partners that are ready
and willing mobilizing champions you
talked about that that is critical you
know not only sector [ __ ] champions but
champions in community old-school street
rallies still are very important I have
I lost so much patience with I went to
so many rallies but there's been that
a resurgence of rallies in the last wall
and you know they get attention you know
ride that hyper information highway and
rocket you got a blog post you got a
tweet you got a Facebook we have to use
what tools are available to us money
really does matter
not just from a funding perspective but
there is such interest in this return on
investment again which I hate it but the
whole kind of return on investment
argument is compelling argument
especially in terms of some of the
tables where we're trying to do this
systems change where creativity juice it
up
I always remember Dina Ladd when she was
doing the $14 an hour wage campaign she
talked about you know it's been the
minimum wage has been frozen at eleven
dollars for how many years and she would
bring eleven dollars frozen into a block
of ice to meetings which I thought was
like wow and she does things like that
all the time very creative like really
making a visual visible point and be
solutions driven you have to be able to
talk about the exact solutions that you
that you that community wants to see and
that you're you're driving towards and
be the change you want to see and so and
be passionate be the change you want to
see I mean I'm fortunate every day I get
up and have an opportunity to go to work
and try to be that change thank you very
much and and I we're gonna you know
we're take a few minutes now for
questions but there were so many things
I think you've packed into there cracked
open
I just want to flag a few that I hope
will kind of come back to either now or
later you know I think there was this
discussion point about undoing the
hierarchical view qualitative versus
quantitative data I assume that really
resonates with people in the room so
let's make sure that comes out in the
discussion or in the group's
this knowledge translation question
about only valuable if it's shared and
used I think there's a lot of richness
in a conversation about that and where
it's happening what's stopping some of
this rich data from being used the
underfunding of community organizations
to actually do this work the money
really really really matters and then
these various dimensions of messiness
that you talked about to use your term
around the ownership of the data the the
researcher versus advocate tension they
were a number of different dimensions I
think that we could call just some of
the complexity and messiness of this
kind of work and this kind of work
together so thank you for cracking so
many things open that I hope we can
revisit but for let's take a couple of
minutes to just take any questions top
of mind that people have so a big fan of
your work and I was wondering do you
have any peers like has anyone followed
in your footsteps when you created the
first research department within a CHC I
don't I'm not sure I'm not sure that
many others have followed that and that
must have been brave and resourceful to
start that and to build that with the
same funding that everybody else gets
are you are you mentoring any others who
are following in your footsteps well
that's a good question
there are a few years and you know
everything has ups and downs a few years
ago there was a committee based research
network that was pulling together a lot
of people that were engaged and they
were meeting but they lost some steam
and I don't I think it's mostly and we
were very active for a period of time
and driving that there are community
health centers and other organizations
that do research but sometimes it's more
one-off or it's a piece of work and you
know or for example there's a sister
commune health center that they do
research but they don't they work with
researchers who come in and so they
still drive a lot of it so it's a
challenge we want to actually get back
to that we're looking at trying to
create a sort of a research advisory
table and for sure in this targets
driven world some you know sometimes we
have to try to figure out how to put
some you know because those staff
they're the funding is its
their unit producing positions that's
what they're called right unit producing
positions so we sometimes need to think
about what are those units we're
recording on this note about it being
kind of courageous and bold they think
is important one what did it actually
take what was the impetus for you just
making that decision to have that
in-house research capacity well I think
it was because we were so focused on
immigrant and refugees and you know
within health commitment evidence-based
there just was no evidence and we were
being so offended [ __ ] constantly by
these calls for can you put us in touch
with this community that you know the
combination of and then we needed
questions answered and there was no
information
[Music]